[Music]
this is how they usually go go live go
live yeah
okay I am live now I should be
okay am I still super loud
I I don't know this this the chat will
soon tell us if you are
okay all right that noise is me drinking
chocolate Bros sorry
I sound like you're like kissing
kiss me like
it's like um a little it's like the soya
chocolate milk stuff that I get um yeah
I've never had that before and they come
in little cartons right yeah yeah
Jackson bought me like three little
cotton things so oh what a what a what a
good man yeah I can't remember he must
have done something I don't know he must
have done something bad yeah
hey I bet Zeta okay let me just explain
what's going on here today I'm gonna be
playing Tick Tock a tale for two but
it's not just for me because I need a
two so the two is
and she's
um she's just like on Discord so you
can't actually see her obviously but
this game's interesting because it's
Co-op and it shows two different
versions of the same game mind blown
so Amy will get one screen that
unfortunately you guys won't be able to
see and neither will I and then I will
get another screen and we have to try
and work out puzzles by telling each
other what we can see on our separate
screens and this game is pretty cool you
can check it out in the description I
think it should be
um it's it's cross-platform so which I
thought was pretty interesting so you
can play on like PC tablet mobile switch
even although you said it was now on
switch yeah no it's out on switch later
like in the month I think so okay
because I was originally gonna play it
on my switch but yeah PC that's so cool
because I was talking about this today
um and we were saying like they must
have taken so much into account because
if you can play this game on a PC but
also on a mobile phone then you've gotta
either make two different like different
versions of the same screen like of the
same scene or you have to really think
and be like okay well obviously I can't
do anything too intricate because if
there's a puzzle piece that you can't
see on a mobile like on a small screen
yeah you know what I mean so yeah put a
lot of time and effort into this so yeah
because if my PC wasn't working I was
gonna play it on my phone so that would
have been interesting yeah yeah
okay so uh let's let's play Jackson Jack
says I'm Amy guys lies
Jackson's like I'm not even lying I
swear
you are
everyone wants to be me I know I get it
it's okay guys
you couldn't Channel me
Channel and that says who are you
playing with uh is Amy yeah I'm I'm your
best friend oh yeah that too like
explaining like maybe they don't they've
never seen any videos with me maybe
maybe not you haven't been in one of my
videos in a while actually no yeah you
were like at the end of the ukulele
unboxing video if you want to check Amy
out check out that video I'm just
wrapped in plastic yeah sort of having a
bad time but yeah
sure
I'm behind the scenes I'm the one that's
usually behind the camera if she's in
Plymouth if I yeah if I'm around you
right now I have no friends but it's
okay because we got the Internet yay
[Laughter]
okay let's start
you starting
yeah wait what is your say I'm just
going through all the things again
telling you to talk on Discord and stuff
so oh okay I've clicked start game so
I'll wait okay so I'm gonna be your
player two yeah I'm player two your
player one yeah okay
what did you say
today you and your friend receives two
strange packages each contained an Old
Clock what does your say mud says you
received a package from someone called
Emily RAV Raven and your friend got one
too Anna Lee Raven
knows r-a-v-m oh oh okay so I wouldn't
pronounce that Raven but maybe so you
know who gave us the packages and I know
what's in them the clocks
oh okay yeah I guess okay so I've gone
next next
uh what okay so I can see a clock a
digital clock it says yep Tuesday Yeah
Yeah Tuesday third of December 2019. yep
and I've got a little letter on the
right on the table and it says Dear
player one the clock is part of a game a
gift I made for my sister to have a oh
oh I've just picked it up yeah me too
uh I gave my a gift I made for my sister
to have a Fighting Chance play with a
friend and tell each other what you read
and see if you find my sister tell her I
miss her oh that's cute oh Emily so
that's the person who gave us the
packages right yeah see mine says
something different it says Dear player
two I said one clock to you and one to
your friends if you want to play a game
look into the past together remember to
wind the clocks up oh okay cool so we'll
wind the clocks up and we have to tell
the sister that we miss her I wonder
what she means by a Fighting Chance oh
okay quick thing so you know what going
down have you got an arrow pointing down
oh yeah I do okay
oh dragon dragon
Okay click and drag okay I've got oh
okay you go
I've got a bit of paper that's ripped
and it looks like the second half oh
sweet okay I'll get up mine because I've
got the same okay so I've got the first
half so at the top it says another
disappearance strip
e I've got k-e-s so strikes a village
okay by Mark D Hansen the youngest
member of the renowned clock maker
family lurk was reported missing
yesterday her sister Emily told us she
had last seen her at 10 30. okay so this
is her sister I guess the one she's
talking about and yeah I've got a
picture here of a building and it's
Ravens so the one who sent the packages
clocks so it's it's hair clock shots
mine says understandably distressed she
later corrected her statement and said
it must have been an hour and a half
later
contacts if you have seen or heard
anything unusual please contact the
police
it says Tuesday March 14th 1937 that's
the date okay so it wasn't 10 30 it was
like midnight
yeah okay cool
okay and then I've got a clock me too
but it won't let me open it what is your
say on it does it have an engraving yeah
l
a e but the AE you're like joined
oh that's that's
um r-ke 1917 to 1937.
so
okay well mine says Emily which makes
more sense because that's obviously the
sister right and I can actually oh you
might be able to open yours like an open
mind just oh I'd just drag it and then
yeah yeah I got it
oh okay so mine was quarter past six but
you can move the hands
oh mine's seven
but I think it's yours broken oh oh we
can remember your thingy said to wind
the clocks
oh we've got to wind them back wind them
back because you can wind the top bit as
well
oh can you I don't think I'm doing
anything yeah no that one doesn't do
anything so wind it back
I don't know what to what time though oh
wait 12 I'm gonna do 12. we should do 12
midnight twelve okay midnight because
that was when she was last seen
midnight and then wind it back wind it
up the top wind it back I'm going into a
Vortex oh yeah
we're so smart
chapter one this is a copy I made of the
world that lurk and I used to know okay
you go
Luke went missing in 1937 but it all
started years before
I like this okay creepy
[Music]
time travel
1927.
cool so I might let the train station
yeah me too do you have a weird
I have no idea how to describe this a
grid I've got a grid yeah a little clock
and then I've got a clock like a big
clock in front of the station bit
I don't have a little clog I've got a
big clock in front of the station but
there's no little clocks oh wait I don't
have a little clock did I say a little
clock yeah oh I think you just changed
your size of the clock
Size Matters God damn it okay
um let's click on the grid it's oh okay
have you got anything on your grid
um so I've just got a little train in
the the bottom left oh me too
and there's arrows it looks like we're
gonna have to do like a path for it so
maybe we need to learn more I'm missing
one of my arrows though are you yes yeah
I'm missing my right
oh me too okay
I thought you might have the one that I
missed yeah hey so I'm talking to the
chat as well
what
um so yeah that's sort of a dead end
right now
I feel maybe I feel like that's
something we come back yeah so you've
got left up and down right right yeah
but not right right right and it's
midnight on the clock I don't know if
you'll said midnight uh
yes yes but
oh okay oh okay we can move it around
yeah we can go left and right I'm gonna
go right so dragged left oh there's a
little else yeah it was a bird
bird bird I've got a white Raven I would
call it there is no bird on my screen oh
I've got a bird like flying all over my
screen like I had him on the last one
but he was like in the distance oh cool
yeah no I don't so clicking
he flew away ah well he's got to be
something though because I don't have
one on my screen oh you can click the
bushes wait what I just went to the
house sorry oh well I'll click the
bushes one sec
okay I'm going back out to collect the
bushes hi
jelly on a plate oh no there's nothing
there they're just wobbling yeah there's
nothing there should we go in
yeah let's go
oh oh my God that's creepy
what it's like a train well I've got
I've got an empty like a shadow of an
empty cage where I'm assuming the bird
came from and then I've got one of those
wind-up puppet boxes you know like that
you wind up and it plays a tune and it
like jumps out of you oh well that's
weird I have something completely
different I have okay what a train quite
like the one well I don't know it's like
it's like a toy train I can wind wind it
up
and I've got a light as well that I can
turn on and off oh and if a moth just
came
and you've got a moss friend yeah
um it said lurk hope like present oh
okay I think if you click something on
yours you'll get the rest of this
because it doesn't make any sense right
now I need to go oh I just stepped out
wait let me go back yeah go back click
on
um I'm gonna wind it oh let's play
Creepy music
maybe I need to wind it backwards oh
it's okay I just made my steam train go
and it says look I hope you like your
present turn it anti-clockwise three
times oh this might be for you
anti-clockwise okay three times oh wait
wait hold up so it says anti-clockwise
three times clockwise twice and she got
wise twice then keep turning it
clockwise
okay okay wait I need to start again
okay no way so you do you do it bit by
bit and I'll tell you what to do okay
wait uh I can't
um
okay yeah how what do I do
anti-clockwise three times no
anticlockwise three times yeah
two
two three okay clockwise twice
one
two
and a clockwise twice
one
one two and then cockfight
oh and do not let go I forgot that part
sorry did I just sorry okay right okay
let me try again
okay right okay anti-clockwise three
times right it's three two three
two
three two
two and then two sorry it says and
clockwise three times clockwise twice
and to clockwise twice and then
clockwise and then don't let go I am the
worst actually just keep going clockwise
now
what did you do
I like clockwise but nothing's happened
what did you do there
okay it jumped out
you did it
that was painful
um oh okay I've got the start of a
ticket it looks like the start of the
train ride that we need to do oh cool
so oh so we know what direction we want
it to go in yeah but we need to find the
right button because that's what we're
missing okay let's go we'll go back then
I think we've done this part
okay
buddy teamwork we need to remember that
though because you can't take it with
you
oh okay take a picture on your phone oh
good job
no worries mantaz you go
um and thanks for letting me know about
this game actually because it was
Montage so let me know about this game
love it I miss Co-op I miss co-op games
I miss just people coming around and
like playing games together it was fun
couch Co-op
okay so we're moving right now hey
Jagger muffin ah yes oh
creepy
oh cool oh my God if you've got a well
yes
it was like little lanterns it's like
the ring right that's the one with the
little girl coming out yeah let's I'm
gonna touch the lanterns I've just
touched some of them
I don't think they're gonna break no
which is good
okay I'm gonna take the well okay oh
okay let's go down the ladder
okay you ready to see the girl oh my
gosh
oh disappointed
um
I've got triangle shapes and square
shapes and they're all sort of lit up
and there's buttons
you don't have any circles no well I've
got buttons they're Circle
oh I see I have mainly circles I've got
one square and one triangle shape
oh I've got three triangles three
squares
we maybe have to match ours up like can
you change oh yeah I can change them to
circles
oh
they changed to All Sorts yeah I know so
how are we supposed to know who's oh
okay so we can only change
certain ones with buttons right and I
bet you've got the other ones okay I'm
with you okay so the first one in the
top left hand corner that one's stuck
for me so should I tell you what that is
yeah so it's a dark triangle
thank you
thank you um we'll just go right from
here so my middle one
is a white circle oh like okay got it
um my last one on that end is a white
triangle
and my one on the next row to the left
is a white square
okay got it my next one is the same a
white square
okay got it should we pull the lever
yeah
there's something inside
the bottom it's a play button how do I
get it
yeah it was the button on it
oh my God it's the bird
no evil
not built
yay okay we did it okay let's go
get out of this creepy well
um let me up all right the arrow don't
forget the arrow the white Raven's back
gets sat on the well oh cool give it a
tap
The Edge flew away it just flew to the
right it's interesting because I don't
have a raven on mine at all so hmm I
wonder why yeah
oh
shoot Raven's clocks
yeah it's yours got uh
like a cog to the right to the right and
left there's cogs everywhere cogs yeah
and the Raven's back okay let's go in
did you click on the raven
yeah I just flew away
oh opening three to nine yeah
let's just say three to nine as well
yeah three to nine oh maybe we have to
change the clock
oh maybe
oh should we keep going right yes keep
going that way we'll end up back around
oh here we go the cogs go around when
you turn oh my God they do look it's one
o'clock in the morning now so should we
keep going just keep going and then
until it gets to three
can we not just change it okay yeah I
think it's I think it's like a big turn
time yeah okay right so we gotta keep
going it works it's two okay it's three
now so I'm gonna go into the shop
okay oh my God sorry the well made a
weird noise
oh I'm going in oh it's going
oh guys let let us know if the audio is
like weird or whatever but I think it's
good and you guys are enjoying the
puzzles and hello Edith Edith Edith
okay
I just
what is this I don't know what I would
call this a an old radio
yes yeah so I've just moved the little
the little um
[Music]
yeah and it says something I'm guessing
you might have the next part so oh it's
got
oh it's all letters okay right uh
are usually followed by the ticking and
scuttling oh hold up I've got the
beginning to that I think
last month the police started getting
several reports of pets going
[Music]
um of mine says I usually followed by
the ticking and scuttling of one well
what's your set to
525 is like literally the very beginning
oh like pretty much
Oh missing mostly old cats and dogs
let's hope they are all found soon
yeah so let's just keep going slowly and
we'll get the next one
okay my next one's by the 8 20. okay it
says the oldest rope oh my God what the
hell there's a what there's like a clock
where a cockroach just randomly come
down the stairs
again okay bye oh mine's just sat there
almost there oh
oh maybe I'll click it
oh yeah okay it's going away now
um yes this is the oldest Raven daughter
Emily it's a brilliant clockmaker an
inventor her footsteps
are usually followed by the ticking and
scuttling of one of her Creations oh
that's why it's coming up and down the
stairs cute yeah
oh next one's like just after 8 20.
The Raven family moved here a month ago
and I've worked day and night
to be able to open their clock shop
today the 18th
doesn't really make sense but okay
okay just after one one one five
another pet has been stolen during the
night this time it was Mrs Jensen's
sweet Old Farm dog remember to lock your
doors until this thief has been caught
[Music]
the jealous I would steal a pet so no I
wouldn't I want one now but for like a
day and then I'd be like okay I feel bad
give it back
um okay so this is before 1410
a strange occurrence has shook our
village droves of lifeless
uh lifeless birds have been found
scattered across the forest floor oh
weird okay
no more walking oh this is like just
after one for one hour yep no more
walking for five miles to get your
letters it's now March time and the
construction of our very own post office
will start at the end of the month
[Music]
before 1705
yeah oh the white Raven okay an unusual
white waving seems attached to the
youngest member of the Raven family
let's hope for her sake that it will not
go missing like those other pets
oh you can go up
my time is stuck at quarter to four
uh yeah
just before quarter to four yeah like
it's true oh they're all stuck yeah yeah
there's um some wallpaper on the floor
so I'm gonna click it I've got white
feathers
no my white feathers they just sort of
jump
and then if you go up
the date is the first oh they were
working tirelessly until the eighth
right so maybe we should
say that the eighth what does yours say
what are you talking about remember just
now we were reading all those things and
I said that the family were working
tirelessly and then you said to open the
clockmakers shop on the 8th
oh right I've got if you scrolled up
from the wallpaper because I've got
something in there yeah yeah oh do you
not have a calendar
no oh okay I've got it says news
Wednesday Edition
um so I'm guessing the Wednesday on your
calendar isn't the eighth maybe
um it says in Raven Raven's clock shop
you can buy all kinds of clockwork
request commissions and get your old
clock repaired today grand opening of
clock shop the world renowned clock
maker Mr blank
the level of oh Mr Evan has opened a new
[__] shop in our town he is sad
to be an interesting
he oh he is said to be an interesting
Char Char
ity oh maybe and then that cuts off and
then there's more the level of detail is
exquisite our own Queen is said to have
a couple of his elegant pieces today he
is opening his shop I guess and does it
have a date on there
no it just says Wednesday Edition
Wednesday okay great all right so
Wednesday I think it's the eighth and
what
we need to find a month
oh a month
um
it was the eighth Freight that you said
earlier
yeah it was definitely the eighth
so now we need to look for a month
something that points to a month
couldn't it be like August because
that's the eighth the eight to the
eighth
or could you just look through the
months and see what month has
a Wednesday on the 8th
that would take forever because
basically like I just have to pick
eight Wednesday Thursday Friday like
it's not like an actual calendar
oh okay I just have to change the day
and
are we being dumb are we missing
something
so you said Wednesday so it's definitely
Wednesday 100 I think we must have
missed I I had it on December because
that's the month that she went missing
but perhaps it was a different month
so should we go back to what the stuff
that we read
yeah let's quickly just go through here
again and see if we missed anything
yeah
I'm just gonna skim through mine and
just look for
yeah something saying a month
yeah you did the same just let me know
well
oh wait
I've got the 18th oh 18. okay 18th so
I'll change that in a second then yeah
[Music]
it's now March time okay oh March 18th
yes
um but it's March time and
the construction of our very own Pope
will start at the end of the month
but they said the Raven probably moved
here a month ago
so I'm guessing it might be a month
before March Maybe
or after
no no before because they moved a month
ago
and then March was when so it must be
just before March
of February and you said the 18th or the
28th 18th
um
I feel like these clocks have got
something to do with it
[Music]
well about September like all the clocks
are put into like
like the nine they're like
that's okay what happens it just opened
up so I can see some books in here about
watchmaking some tools but also oh I've
got the other half of the ticket
why do you guys have such difficult
names I'm not gonna finish playing um no
I I haven't stopped what are you going
to end your other gameplay within the
King Kong game alienization hell no that
would take me forever and I don't even
think I have my saves of those games
anymore
I still gotta finish Resident Evil 2 and
like a bunch of other games and start a
bunch of other games so probably not
um okay
let me take a picture
there's too many games
don't complain about that
no but you can never play them all or
finish them all no
okay
like everyone's like Play Devil May Cry
I'm like I still haven't played so many
eyes on the Kingdom Hearts yeah
uh my friends are obsessed with Kingdom
Hearts
okay so I've got my picture so let's
head back
cool oh it's four now
we'll put the put the button in
oh yeah it's a bottom yeah
okay so you've got the first half so let
me know where to go just guide me okay
um let me just give it a picture
okay so go up to
yep yep then across uh right sorry one
two three
write three write three yeah
um down twice
and then across once and that's when
mine stops cool yeah
so we want to go up three times
yep and then right twice
uh-huh
up once
yep and then right again once
oh something is happening
boom okay still back oh the train
there's a train on the hill
should we go upstairs
yeah chapter two hell yes we progressed
it was getting harder to find animals
for my experiments oh that's what they
were doing with the animals oh but I
still knew no one I could get access to
easily
well it says people sorry okay that's
all right I told Lark uh I was Miss
making her a clock but she wasn't
interested she was too busy playing with
her stupid bird
cute
he went missing for his experiments
whoever this is who is this
I don't know what to did you click the
next one 1932 yeah yeah oh okay good
night
oh yeah it's like all it's raining oh
Thunder yep
and then do you see like our old track
but like a big red x on it yeah out of
service track and it's midnight again
okay let's go the same way right yeah
wait wait there's something on top of it
oh no it's just a flower never mind okay
I don't have the bird I can't see it oh
okay
okay so I've got the house again okay
let's go into the house okay
have you got the fireplace
uh no I've got loads of bells like
um it says kitchen front door study
Music Room office dining hall
like they're all rigged up so someone
Belle is in those rooms wait uh from do
you have front room
uh front door
no study I've got study or office maybe
maybe you're in those try those do those
bells
oh wait no I wouldn't be able to hear it
because it's not hooked up right damn it
yeah and there's I've got a plant pot
with some with like a bit of paper under
it oh
says I left you something downstairs it
will be my greatest invention yet play
our secret Melody and I'll open the door
so all the bells ring slightly different
so I need to
bring a certain Melody okay okay I have
a door to the basement by the way oh
okay I've got
I've got a door but if I knock it all
the bells Go at once
I'm not allowed in the basement
it's not letting me go down there no I
guess it's because we'll need to find
so I've got uh no I am going down there
sorry I had to drag
Okay so
I've got rope oh and the Rope has words
on them there's also a cage down here
are you still there oh wait yeah I'm
still here
so wait I've got a barrel with something
oh more words okay
so I'm guessing you'll have words
to tell me what to do like kitchen study
to tell me which order to go maybe
there's a salamander
yeah I caught him and I got more words
oh they're all coming together now okay
right I've been working on this
iteration for one year now in the study
study study okay I'll click that one
first
I'd like you to keep it safe for me lark
look after it really well like you did
with the two kittens you found and the
pantry two two maybe
Pantry would that be kitchen
yeah I have laundry kitchen okay
try it like just try doing it once and
then if that doesn't work we'll try
twice because it says two kittens so
yes okay I think it is because it says
one year in the study two kittens in the
pantry but we'll we'll just do it like
this now and then we'll see yeah and
next one is five so yeah it makes sense
in five years when I've gained more
knowledge I'll come back and complete it
I'll be sitting by the dinner table
waiting for you
knowledge so that would be office and
then dining hall because there's a
dining hall
or that would be just the dining hall
yeah
dining hall okay
did anything happen
no is that the end of it yes okay right
so we think I think it's yeah to do with
the the numbers so study hey zombie and
Kiki
so um yeah one study uh-huh
hmm
two pantry
uh kitchen yeah
yep five knowledge
it's a study
five knowledge yeah
uh-huh
and then it says
I'll come back and complete it I'll be
sitting by the dinner table waiting for
you so dining hall one yeah I guess
mark
no nothing happened
[Music]
maybe it's
one study two kitchen wait pantry
yeah there must be kitchen so one study
two kitchen and then maybe five dining
hall
yeah maybe maybe not the study at all
yeah try this yeah
yes it opened
okay how do I go in there
what the door oh maybe it's the same as
me try and like click and drag down go
underneath
oh okay yeah it is yeah you're right oh
wow okay so we've got loads of stuff
um
okay so there's
a rope holding a barrel
that's just hanging above the floor and
the shelves behind that with like
just like old paint pots and plant pots
and glass jars that are empty and two
wooden boxes that won't open
so have you cooked everything does
anything
happen uh I can move one of the little
pots
um
clicking around and there's like
things that I could so I clicked like a
salamander and it moved and then I had
to like move all the pots and stuff to
get it to keep moving Keep On Moving
oh
oh I just hit the barrel and it's
breaking open cool
oh it's not
okay I just have to beat up this Barrel
go for it a clock fell out of it
okay and it's just
oh okay this is going to different times
I think it's showing me a code okay so
it goes midnight three o'clock midnight
Midnight midnight
three o'clock six o'clock
and that's it so twelve three twelve
three 12 12
3 6 6
. they're all kind of like devilish
times so
twelve three twelve twelve twelve three
six okay
if you've written that down somewhere no
it's just ingrained guys remember it in
chat please thank you please
benefits of streaming yeah
okay cool that's
gone that was it oh now everything's all
rainy I know
yeah kind of
I'm just gonna move the pots again
okay
um
I'm gonna go into this trumpet shop
have you gone outside oh yeah oh okay uh
yeah trumpet shot got it
[Music]
I've got a post office
oh I guess oh I don't know okay so um
yeah I've got like
safe
what are these
what are you here
um a post box like a red
post box with like in the wall
um
and it says post and then a word that I
can pronounce and then there's like
Scrolls
okay do they have any numbers on them or
like
symbols
uh no
because I've got these things that I can
like turn their hands to make different
shapes
um they've got like
four pointers and I can turn them around
in a circle to make different types of
shapes and they say 44 46 and 48.
sorry
I don't have any of that I'm clicking
everything but nothing's happening
there's nothing that you could help me
with like trying to figure out what
shapes
oh I've got more Jesus Christ I'm going
all the way up and there's like tons oh
wait you're scrolling up I can't yeah
it's scrolling up
I can't move like I don't get anything
and so the was it post box it doesn't
have anything in like in the Scrolls or
no the Scrolls just won't let me unravel
them the post box says post
Cassie
and it has a picture of a trumpet on it
and then there's nothing happens
no
you can't click and drag on the Scrolls
uh no
I've been clicking everything let me
drag anything
this is weird
yeah because usually it's like
each screen helps each screen you know
what I mean yeah so what have you got
they're literally they look like massive
safes or something but where there's
like a big circle with four pointers and
I can just put them different places in
the circle and button and numbers 14 all
the way to 48.
so the numbers from before won't help
what numbers
the ones from the clock midnight and
stuff
no yeah cause that was like twelve three
three six
no because there's one two three four
five six seven eight nine there's 12 of
them
oh my God no I've got nothing
and I can't they're not clocks so it's
like there's four hands not two
how many do you need in total
okay
no I don't know
maybe we should just go to the next bit
see if there's anything else okay
what's got the clock
Raven's clocks
oh was that the
the post place that they were gonna
build that's weird I guess
okay it opens at three so let's do the
same thing again then okay cool
[Music]
it's open
oh okay I've got a letter
what's your name I've Got The Raven
Raven I've got Emily
it says Emily RAV Raven or Raven on her
neck on her letter and there's two posts
there's two stamps and it looks like
there's a key in there he has a key in
there
okay oh I picked it up okay I picked it
up
and there's a key to a [__] shop that
I've just picked up too so
the the what the clock shop
yeah I've got a key to a clock shop and
a letter
to Emily with a key in it
what does the Lesser say
oh no it's like an envelope sorry oh
okay with the key in it
I think
it's okay I'm
uh and I've got a box with Lark on it
that won't let me open it
a picture
of the Raven with Emily
and a plant and a clock
hmm
what do you have I have
um
some drawers that I can't open
some books on extracting time and
creating automate automations Auto me
auto automaton
automaton I don't even freaking know
what that is
um I'm guessing let's do a cogwork and
Raven and so
um
I've got a note that says do not remove
these tools I will work when the clock
shop is closed from Emily and there's
like some tools on the desk that I can't
pick up some marbles that they wouldn't
do anything and I've also got an
apprenticeship no like uh certificate
sorry that says Dear Emily I am pleased
to inform you that you have been chosen
as my new Apprentice your experiments
for time extractions are truly
groundbreaking I agree that our short
lifespan is deeply unfair especially for
people like us who keep improving the
world pushing it forward I'm looking
forward to helping you with your
experiment in Switzerland hmm you're
sincerely and it's got C
[Music]
he was on your post box
Master watchmaker
on my post box no it said post and then
this long word that I couldn't pronounce
which I'm just maybe maybe a Swiss
shut up
hmm
not sure
I wonder what these keys are for
so you picked them up right and they're
like in your inventory
yeah okay maybe
yeah shall I go back to the trumpet
Place yeah let's go back
oh I can put I can oh I posted the
letter oh
I posted the letter and then I got post
box number 28. oh
oh okay let me find 28. okay I got 28.
okay and then it says
like NW like Northwest
[Music]
I know but how
all of these
do you have like a compass like what's
that about no
there's four arms in a circle it's like
a clock but with four arms oh okay so
you do northwest
yeah but it's four arms
yeah so I've got four things to tell you
so I've got Northwest west southwest
east oh okay sorry I should have said
that so I mean okay Northwest yeah
West
Southwest
and then East
okay
it's open
yeah what happened
wow people are talking about deep deep
frying potatoes
oh it gets so weird so quickly I don't I
don't know I'll let them have their fun
um so it's a letter to Emily Raven hey
you just posted your letter right maybe
I've got the keys
maybe yeah I do I have the keys
oh cool okay here's your key to the
clock shop Emily when you're done
working could you help me look for my
Raven I know where the Raven is I was
just looking at her she's in the clock
shop okay so back to the clock shop I
guess back to the clock shop
to the clock shop wait which way is that
right
oh yeah
okay so I've got this key that I don't
know why I need it but also she was
looking for her Raven and it's here
the Ravens in the clock shop yeah but I
don't need to use this key because I'm
already in here oh she let's said do not
remove the tools I'll work when the shop
is closed so we need to keep on going to
the shops closed
oh okay right I might just go back in
time so go the other way go
anti-clockwise okay cool
I'm gonna use the key now
oh you won't be able to get in though I
don't think
oh I have a key oh you already have a
key you must give me yes sir then I'm
going in oh okay okay so there's a clock
here that I'm trying to fix
oh see I've got everything's the same
apart from I've have two books I've got
one on gemstones and one horology which
I don't know what it is
I'm gonna google it
so I've got stones in my [__] so it
probably has something to do with it
stop yes the Raven keeps on hitting my
clot stop get off the clock you stupid
Raven oh horology is the study of
measurement of
it's like hour like okay
um I've got three
no six different stones
I've got okay I've only got four in mine
okay which colors do you have
there's like
um I guess it's green yeah
I've got well this one's green it says
the malachite is a mineral known for a
green color and could be used to create
durable pigments no it's not really
helpful is it no
what's the other one I got red red the
Ruby is a hard and durable gemstone that
can ease friction in mechanical
instruments
clear or white yeah quartz is commonly
used in the making of clocks due to its
ability to channel energy
Brown yeah a tiger's eye can be used as
a conductor due to its layering of
quartz crystals
that's my favorite I love Tiger's eyes
so I can change
like they're all kind of next to each
other but I can change where they are so
is there anything in your books to kind
of say how they should be positioned
next to each other or anything like that
I mean there's the I could tell you
which order they are in the book that I
can look at yeah
um I've got so I've got green
then the white then red and then the
tiger's eye
so I've also got other stuff to fiddle
around within the clock
so I've got I've got two other Stones
here
what are the stones
uh a Dalmatian Stone says white with
black dots uh conducts energy it's less
powerful than a quartz but doesn't wear
down as fast and then a black one and
Onyx can be used as a type of insulator
to slow down smaller electric currents
when we look at the other book
oh yeah they saw that this other book
yeah this will help hey Tom 's in chat
okay
I've got a book that's by seashore
um new methods of measuring time
accuracy as you got
I think I know what you're looking at is
it sort of a semi-circle with four
stones in the
yeah yeah okay right I'm looking at that
um through multiple studies Miss Shaw
figured out that a timepiece would be
more precise when using only quotes in
the channeling plate
I think the sequence will be more
accurate with the additional benefit of
storing time the Tiger's eyes should be
to the left of the chords so we need the
White and the tiger's eye the malachite
cannot be to the far side or directly
next to the Ruby the Ruby must not be
directly next to the tiger's eye okay
wait one sec so
it must be on the left right
yeah should be left to the courts
um so the white which one's the quartz
again just do the the white one so white
yeah um so the brown one should be to
the left of the white yeah
the green cannot be to the far sides or
directly next to the red
the red must not be directly next to the
Brown
so wait and the brown must be on the
very left
of the white so maybe the white so far
right okay okay okay hold up
uh there's another page let me read the
uh
right so
the the brown must be to the left of the
white yes yep the green
must not be next to oh the red or on the
outside no I think the green just must
not be on the wait the malachite cannot
be to the far sides or directly next to
the roof they can't be on the right side
okay so that's that's fine so the brown
must be to the left of the white
I can't be next to the no it can still
be to the left just not directly next to
it so we could do white
green oh wait
wait why oh yeah why
something wait no you set the brightness
would be to the left or the right yeah
but it can still be to the left of it
just not directly next to it so we could
do white green
Reds
I won't know oh wait are you going from
right to left or left to right
right to left no left to right
because if the white is first
then the green wool no the brown will
have to be
right of it
yeah
bye so
it so Browns must be left to the right
yeah
okay and then white must be
just
the right of the the brown there's
nothing there's no more rules
white can be wherever it wants but the
brown one has to be to the left of it
and then then the green cannot be on the
sides
size I'm not next to the red
okay so it doesn't this doesn't
necessarily have to be and the Reds
cannot be next to the Brown
[__] I literally just moved it to me
next to the brown
what the hell had it
um like a duck right
I was directly next to the review
I think it must go
Ruby I think you should try red white
green brown
but then want the green
B to the wait the Brown's still to the
left of the word wait no
oh wait no I'm getting my another mixer
okay the other way the other way or the
opposite
I can't easily I have to like like slide
them all around so it's like oh okay so
I see basically I'm doing what I've got
now but the other way round I think
oh my God
and then my next page talks about
balancing a needle so yeah I've got I've
got that too okay cool we can get to
that
with white brown green
no red white green brown but the other
way so brown green yeah white rest okay
cool yes okay do you reckon that's right
yes I do okay
needle okay so balance so the highest
Precision point the balance needle
towards the third quartz
uh and then she's putting out in point
it instead towards the malachite stores
time better so point it towards the
green one
and everything that felt more accuracy
wind the clock up by turning the top
right gear clockwise twice once the lid
has closed test the experiment by
setting the clock to 12. this should
initiate the extraction process
well I've got I've got two cogs
um
also I've got like gray and white
parameters around the pointer that I've
pointed to the green
Crystal
does it say whether I need to
do it on a white or a gray
uh no it just says
point it to the Mallet to the green
okay let me balance that again to me
please
okay so for the highest Precision point
the balance needle tool oh wait for the
highest Precision point the balance
needle towards the third quarter green
when everything is set for optimal
accuracy wind the clock up by turning
the top right gear clockwise twice wait
wait the top
gear
yeah okay cool because I've got multiple
gears so um okay and then top right gear
what is it clockwise twice
and then once the lid has closed test
the experiment by setting the clock to
12.
oh
the lid hasn't closed maybe it's this
one
what no that's the bottom one
[Music]
two
one two
clockwise
yeah I'm doing it like all the gears
um maybe yeah maybe we've not got the
stones in the right place
God damn it
I don't know why it did it okay
it's like clicking things okay so the
lid is closed yeah the lid closed okay
set the clock to 12. okie dokie
goodness oh there you go Raven just got
sucked into the clock I didn't go
anywhere but the Raven did
and now the clock is going oh [__] it's
doing the freaking thing it's oh what
the hell it's going it's three three
three uh six what the [__] are you doing
quarter pounds
quarter past quarter past quarter past
half past quarter past oh the thing that
happened to me half past quarter past
quarter past quarter past quarter past
half past quarter fast should I go back
to the place that that happened to me
half past quarter past
where was that I can't remember
uh it was in the house house okay I'll
go back to the house
uh Hey panty virus
uh I'm not quite sure who potato Lord is
or Lord potato is for
uh
I don't I've gone back to the clock but
it's just doing the same thing it's
doing 12 3 12 12 12
3. six
big hand
oh my my big hands moving as well I'm
gonna write this down
what's wait let me write mine down
so 12. no no
it's not 1236 is
12 15 12 30 isn't it
that's no my son that's how clocks work
right
mine's on the aloe
oh wait no yeah it is no no I'm being
dumb
the hours
it's okay yeah so it's like on the hour
quarter past on the hour on the on the
hour past half past right so I'm not
gonna listen to you because I'll get
confused
you want me to write yours down
yeah go for it so
um it's quarter past quarter past
quarter past half past quarter past half
past half past quarter past
so you don't have an age what like now
yeah it never goes back to the hour
hmm
of wait where's your hour
and then it does it twice it turns twice
and my my hour hand is on midnight yeah
it's on 12. okay yeah same yeah mine
goes around twice I think it's just to
show that it's starting the sequence
again
I'm guessing we probably have to do that
back at the station the train like those
because it's going oh
do you think it's directions so it's
going like down up up oh my God yes I
reckon that is what it is yeah should we
try yeah should we do it the same way
because you you went first last time
right so should we try you again first
do your player one
I know I'm player one but last time you
had the first half of the ticket
so okay it would still be the same if
not then we'll just try it the other way
around try it the other way okay cool so
are you back at the grid
okay so we go up
uh
right
yep
up up
yep right
down
and then yours is
3336 so right right right
down
uh right and then
down down right oh this
this is the thing yeah
smart oh I put my arm in the air and
then I like flip my mind it was like
please oh the Train's back so we click
the train yes
easier than I thought to extract time
from the from animals are so mean now I
had to learn how to do the same with
people
I've got a new like wouldn't want to
harm the people who went into the clock
so I decided to give them a way out
you knew who luck luck or the I don't
know how we say that name dude yeah okay
dude so they're in the clock but they
can get back out again
yeah I think so that's interesting
oh
okay
are you at like a
[Music]
like a clock you can click the lights on
yeah
yeah that's hands on
the lights on the gate but I guess we
need to turn on all the light bulbs to
turn all the all the lights to get
into the gate
or like a code yeah
okay so should we keep going the same
way as we always go so we can see yeah
yeah
uh oh there's more yeah let's keep
turning them on
okay house
oh I'm gonna have to go soon yeah I was
thinking me too but that's okay we'll
just quickly see how quickly we can do
this if we get stuck we'll just go
okay
wait one second Jackson
let me Chuck something at him
um
do you want to order
okay here all right hungry I'm hungry
too
yeah
um just give me the phone when you've
ordered yours and I'll order mine we're
getting pizza
oh yeah well I've got work
get for lunch
yeah yeah I want to make some packages
for tomorrow yeah tips
no the book was called horology
okay so I've got a clock no I've got a
telephone what have you got
an old school telephone yeah same thing
I've got numbers missing I've got like
the bottom half of the clock I'd say
okay yeah I've got one two three and
four with a star a hashtag and a zero
okay I've got five six seven eight nine
with a plus and a like a squiggly Dash I
don't know what that's called
oh
oh cool okay oh my God
my number one actually I didn't press
zero wait let me go back and then do
this again oh mama
let me go back how do I oh no
okay oh crap wait maybe you should oh
wait I clicked the
click the little phones thing it goes
back okay
[Music]
is that what we usually get
yeah okay
sorry that's okay
professional
um okay what does your number one say
I mean I've got number zero but I don't
think these are in order because they
don't really make sense but I'll I'll go
from zero to four because that makes
sense right yeah
um okay so you named Cole no that can't
be it that can't be it right I'm gonna
read the one that seems the most obvious
so number two says hey look I'm so glad
you finally is there anything that
you've got that would go off to that
quite well
um glad she finally decided to pick up
the phone okay yeah I've been lit wait
and he's oh he's got my phone I need a
pen
just give it back then
[Music]
um it's number seven decided to pick up
the phone I've been leaving and then
do you have anything that goes with that
um I've been leaving just that is that
yeah I've been leaving I've been leaving
earlier but you never mind are you still
angry
wait are you still
are you still
um
are you still there you know your Raven
that went missing the one
you named Carl I made a new one for you
it's upstairs and it's even better it's
one that cannot die oh creepy
is that it because I have so much stuff
that I haven't yeah I've still got stuff
that I've got uh
oh wait I could just
let me go back do you have a beginning
on yours as well
um
no
decided to pick up
um
it's even better this one cannot die
no I've got no starters of like
sentences
hmm
use so many messages wait I know you're
still can know it's not the same but
please just go see for was pouring down
and made me scared
know that before I left I made you
something to keep I guess it's just that
right they want to go so the Raven is
where
uh it's
it's gone
I think it's upstairs
where it's upstairs it just says it's
upstairs it's even better this one
cannot die
okay
wait should we put the numbers in
because there's like a sequence of
numbers that comes up in there I feel
like that's important numbers in where
so when you put the numbers in
um I've got like a white box that shows
the numbers that I've dialed yeah me too
but what do you want to do
you want to do I don't know like I feel
like the sequence was important
um yeah it probably is uh
okay so mine starts with two
two
I just like there's those ones that we
haven't used
yeah I'm not sure I don't know I think
we should just keep on looking around
okay cool let's just look around let's
let's move
there's
something
lights
I've got one of those um
oh they called
ah oh God what are they called
you know like when you do the SOS for
like in beeps
oh
um
I don't know what you mean
Morse code
Morse code yeah
[Music]
so don't watch the borrow it no it's not
the borrowers what is that little thing
with the mouth The Rescuers
the rescue I don't understand what you
mean Morse code I've got this thing that
does Morse code
oh
I've got
circles
with buttons and they've got numbers
like 44 46 48
wait is it the same as what I had did
the circles have loads of like arms yeah
yeah they do before yeah oh this is what
I have now
okay
hmm okay should we keep going yeah
I think maybe we just explore this and
then go because I'm actually getting
really hungry now yeah me too of the
pizza is getting ordered so oh it's dark
in here I don't like it
oh we can go inside oh my gosh it is
very dark
oh I've got loads of symbols do you I
can't
I can't scroll down I've gone to the
basement
oh me too on a box right and you can
kind of move them maybe yeah
you just click them
oh I turn it on
oh
show me a raven
oh I have to keep a raven
all right let me click let me click a
raven
I've seen a snake you click a snake
oh wait
I pressed on again sorry let me let me
click the screen
oh
it it gave me an X it said I did the
wrong thing oh I need to do it okay what
what do you see now
didn't you click the raven
Oh I thought you were supposed to pick
the one that I was seeing okay and now
you said a snake and now what yeah wait
um let me think Ravens
snake
are you seeing anything now
okay so with that Raven take the raven
snake
click the snake
but I don't see anything else it just
says one
and then it's like I'm out of time
Raven snake
unless I gotta press on again
next it just turns off
hmm
like oh it says full
so maybe I'm gonna press
seven isn't it it's all different
numbers
are yours numbers
it gives you a different number like
what happens to you after you put in the
snake
it just says dot dot
where it says like it gives me different
numbers
oh
that's fish yeah
so I've got a raven and then a snake and
now I've got number eight so one two
three four five six seven I don't know
I'm trying to count from like different
spaces
one baby so if this is one
and then eight you said one no and now
it's nine one two three four five six
seven eight
I don't know I don't know maybe we
should come back to it
oh yeah
oh
what
I went back to that uh
that Tower
oh
it won't open for me it's probably
um it's probably a pattern that we need
to find out and we need to recreate
okay
so we should come back yay
oh
right should we just end it there
I think it's a good place to end it was
kind of hangry
I literally came straight home from work
and just got off my computer yeah are
you on it
hungry now
let's do it okay cool thanks with me
oh yeah thanks for inviting I guess
it's time
yeah it's fun we'll do it again
when we're free yeah well we'll figure
out when we break free but it's a cool
game I like it it's cool it's cool yeah
yeah it looks cool yeah it's like weird
to play a game with someone
like for not see the same things it's
awesome yeah explain things
yeah yeah we'll get really good at
describing stuff to each other though
yes that's very true yeah and yeah so
pretty to be going sorry
cheese
hopefully you can catch the next one
yeah anyway
um have a lovely day or evening do you
want to say goodbye Amy
bye guys this is fun